you have a new 16 month old right baby
[Applause]
moments that you've had well there
recently very recently
he's 16 months now and you know it's
like you learn what they understand or
what they do like what they're absorbed
being what they're not absorbing and he
was eating dinner and my husband said
something that really annoyed me as
husband's do and I don't know your
friend and I'm like kinda raised my
voice at him I was probably like Ryan
and Baz my son went he went mom no no
like that and I was like like I like my
heart broke because I was like oh no I
like I'm a horrible you know well yeah
it was just like he was putting me in my
place that I was kind of really proud of
him for doing that but you know it was
like you're right I'm sorry mom you
shouldn't raise your voice at daddy and
acted like apologized it oh my gosh my
poor children are you know usually we
don't argue really my husband i but like
we're both very passionate yes very bad
household is probably what you know what
you should do I'm also very bad like
people call it screaming I just thought
like talking this is how about me I'm 11
I'd say I am too
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this